just like the Backstreet Boys I am back
for the hundred and twentieth time I'm
here on the streets of any town USA to
find out exactly what Americans think of
the news over the last couple weeks more
importantly the Kermit abortion doctor
mass murderer mad scientist Gosnell and
if you're expecting the answers to
surprise you
you're about to get skunked again big
news week obviously new to news weeks
what was your reaction when you first
heard about the Boston I thought it was
very tragic so sad that there are people
like that in the world that do such
horrible things didn't they said Boston
Marathon and I thought that that was a
gas station what I'm just really really
shocked to be fair there probably is a
marathon gas station in Boston so you're
not you're not wrong when you first
heard about the explosion in Texas what
was your reaction hoping it wasn't
terrorist I first thought it was in
relation to what happened in Boston I
gotta tell you that that surprised me
because I took you for a choo-choo man
you one airplane finally what's been
your reaction Washington the Gosnell
trial unfolds this week I don't know
about the Gosnell trial I have no idea
what you're talking about I don't even
know what that is do you do you know
about who karma God knows No
actually don't know
[Music]
at the end of the day out of everyone we
asked only one person had even heard the
name Kermit Gosnell let alone knew that
a trial was going on and why is that why
is the media choosing not to cover a
trial that involves a drug dealer /
multiple time murderer it seems like it
would be catnip to reporters and anchors
across this country could it be maybe
I'll put forth here that it doesn't
quite mesh with their ideals that maybe
what Kermit Gosnell was doing hits a
little too close to home it's not all
that different from what goes on in
abortion clinics across the country when
it's just a mirror in or out
technicality could that just be
something that may not be quite so
convenient to cover for today's news
reporters and anchors in the mainstream
media or maybe their mind was just
elsewhere I heard Brian Williams
with our new Studios by giving you a
little an early look here sorry its door
seems to be